4を
性感帯だこんにちははじめシャツのです今日は2人の協力者に作って雪ですどうぞ
愛というわけで今回この大人数でないでしょうかといいますと
皆さんと出会ってしてますか糸電話結構長い距離をやってる動画とかいくつかあって
俺が見た中で最高の長さは100メートル100メートルから
フィット電話の校 max ですねやってたんですけどレバー今はネット社会なので
どこにいたもね line 通話とか
デーまで全部テーマできると思うんですけどもしこの
妻が地域に陥ったとき我々はどうやって連絡とるんですか
1000メートルの距離だったらどうやってるんだ香鳥屋んですかとりあえずか
1000メートル離れた人と電話どうする場合に会いに行くぞ
遅い華があってくださいけど line とかねネットとかテーマとか使う目状態でも
1000メートル先のちょっと会ができる方法僕を見つけて欲しいと思いました近い
将来ですよねそれで今日はファイトデーはは1000メートルで実験してみようと思い
ますで場所ばですね今回はそこら辺は人がいるんですけどもこっち側はもう人がいなく
てずーっと一直線で
直線で1000m くらい続いていると思われます1000m が多分準備しているの
でここで一緒に今回1000m で行くと電話をしてみようと思います
出会いぞああやばいやばいよねこちらが1000メートル分の糸でございますこういう
意図が一番ほっと月変わりやすいらしいねこれで今回やっていきますだ2種類あると
思うんですけどまずは基本テーパーなので強い紙コップティッカーやってみましょう
カブトムシってでも7月がピークじゃないって言わ方は早いけどが認めちゃうと言うと
本当にこういう感じで穴を開けまあ
しここに糸を通します毎晩すぐ無理か上 dvd で作れないよ
こんばんに難しいかワクワクさん松木れる女抱きたくてきたも曲やりましてきました
ok ですね内側からセロハンテープで留めます相手で片方は鑑定しましたこういう
感じでいいとではを作っていきますとでも方を完成したのでこっちは弟にもってもらい
ますこういう偏りを持ってもらってマットもらって下さ
うんメートル分の1頭いますが僕が2つあつまでで向こうで糸電話を作って果たして
こっちと向こうの糸テーマで1000メートルの距離感を受信できることを助けてみる
目指す確かめてみようと思います第5
糸電話をしようとしてるんですけど1ゲームはへこの辺はちょっとはずですよ
凝った6帖がたらいいこっち側だったらばからサーレございます入ってあげさっそく今
から1000メートル歩いていきますではいってきます
大丈夫怖い怖いはい愛知受け始まりました店名トリート電話でございますこれ果てし
なくて結構
私ないねぇ
魚すげーじゃないよ
ペンチェックどうなってんのこれ
わかんないの考えなく見えないよね家だもうわかんない
ああ
ええええええ
me
熱湯を結構来たんですけどもご覧ください
行く手は肌右手トラッカー十勝ルーフどうするで行って見て来ようっ
じゃあ
これは海をも超えるよペットロボット引っかかるの強いんだけどこれぐらいなら大丈夫
ギリギリ声でした女ので子供参っちゃいましょう
ますいくのが先か実感八石山なさないんでこの角度でいかないと
pot こっちゃ生まれて頃テトラポッドギリギリくらいですか
ところはい
それでなんとかちょっとなポッドの闇や素敵だと思います上手い事を交わして何とか
直線今ではて泣いていると思うので引き続きこの先を歩いていこういこう
動画は目前だ
俺様 meets 結婚できるんだろうと思ったよ
アートバッ
ファーもう結構数はまず
ポツン様終わると思いますじゃねぇ
もうフラもうもうちょい
はいみなさんをご覧下さい戻ってきますイラスト
まあ
a
ああああはしましょうああああ
くれていますわー
ひとまずここら辺で10m ございます
熱中症ですん
こっち側でもいいと点を作っていきます汽笛特急券完成しました
魚ハル姉というわけで実際に1000メートル先の人といったテーマで電話できるのが
実験してみましょう
緊張してきたもしもし麻雀ハイピッチャー1000m 地点には到達しました卑屈から
ちょいジャンスカ上図はどうすればいいと思う
ハッハー紙コップほどメスもうこういうことこういうことをこう
ok じゃあ今からラインで起きるかな神突破に向かっておいで喋ってくださいはーい
じゃあ it
いうことで弟の声が聞こえると思います聞いてみましょう
もうしまーす
を使用して
それはござ4
小沢しまーす
はぞあ
何も聞こえねえや